what's up guys welcome to the sunny with
a chance so random virtual reunion demi
lovato didn't waste any time getting
real while chatting with her former
Disney Channel cast mates how's
everybody doing what does everybody been
up to since the show everybody all at
once go during the combo the twenty
seven-year-old got a candid about
battling an eating disorder and filling
overworked during her time on sunny with
the chance Vinnie's co-star tiffany
thornton recalled the moments she knew
something was wrong and you weren't
sleeping let's be a hundred percent
honest you would stay up all night you
were unmedicated in a way that you
really needed i mean stay up all night
and you come to set the next day and you
would sleep in between scenes because
you were exhausted and I'm like what did
you do last night you're like I wrote
like 12 songs no so true I wasn't
sleeping and like I also I was just so I
was so miserable and like angry because
I was being over she also opened up
about why she kept her dressing room at
98 degrees every day just heard I was
underweight and freezing I had your
dressing room after you did and I am a
furnace of a human being I'm always hot
all the time but for some reason I kept
that dressing room at like 98 degrees I
think your spirit lived on in the room
literally my lunch breaks because that's
how much I work and I would have people
over every lunch break you had a meeting
yeah and so I would like people would
come in like blanket on the couch
they're like why is it 80 degrees in
here and I was like oh the confident
singer revealed that when she went off
to treatment for the first time her
co-star Tiffany was her inspiration
a way to treatment for the first time I
remember like you were my biggest
inspiration coming up a bit because you
like don't lift all of those pressures
of being a woman on TV I looked at that
is like god I wish I had that so bad
like yes I probably like was happier in
my head with like whatever I looked like
at the time but like I'm so much happier
now like with the mentality that you
have that I look back and I'm like man
like it's it's it's a shame that we
wasted any energy thinking about what we
wore on set like I went to Will & Grace
this this time and I like literally
spent 10 minutes in the wardrobe room
used to my fittings would be like an
hour you know didn't but now I'm just
like young doesn't matter like what I'm
wearing does not matter
Vimy was 19 when she said goodbye to
sunny after its second season she admits
that she was surprised a show carried on
without her spinning off into the series
so random I'm not gonna lie it was
humbling for me too because when I left
you know it was like you you don't
expect the show to go on without you but
it did and I but I couldn't have been
happier for everybody and I also just
wasn't in a period of time where I was
ready to be on camera again and I you
know I could I could not go back into
that environment and there was other
things that factored into it in 2017 six
years later after Demi left sunny with
the chance she opened up to eats he
about learning to see herself in a
better light I focus on just what I see
in the mirror and that's a beautiful
person and regardless of what I think of
my body that day I know that nobody can
take Who I am away from me when it comes
to what might lie ahead in Demi's future
I'm in a new chapter in my life
the 27 year old admits that she is
considered stepping away from the
spotlight to live a happier and
healthier life realizing that as I've
gotten older because when I was young I
kind of just when you start off in the
industry as a seven year old
eight year old whatever you kind of
value yourself work with
your success and I'm sure Alice and you
can like relate to that because we were
so young on the show you but like I've
definitely had I have moments all the
time where I'm like do I want to
continue this or do I want to just do a
bullet if innate and like move to Texas
and have a family and have a farm one
thing Demi knows for sure is that while
Sonny will always have a place in her
heart she would rather leave it in the
past I love all of you guys so much but
I went through so much during that show
that I would rather just start a whole
new project letting all of you recorded
zoom before she logged off Demi shared
advice for young people coming up in the
entertainment industry I would just say
like always speak up for your needs you
know always tell the people around you
um if you're tired tell them you're
tired hear sick be honest about you know
being sick and not feeling good just
speak up for yourself
[Music]